l'établissement public
interdépartemental des yvelines et des
hauts-de-seine est entré dans sa phase
opérationnelle
le conseil d'administration réuni ce
matin à nanterre a voté la fusion des
sociétés d'économie mixte des deux
départements
ce matin donc nous avons pris des
décisions importantes autour de
l'aménagement du territoire
l'aménagement du territoire pour être
bref simple clair c'est la construction
de logements et d'équipements la
construction de logements pour loger les
illinois les alto séquanais et les
équipements qui vont avec ses
constructions de logements une nouvelle
structure a vu le jour ce matin site
alios une structure commune
d'aménagement dirigé par les élus locaux
ces missions ça va être de trop service
des communes en particulier et de leur
apporter toutes les compétences avec en
même temps
toute la réflexion que nous allons
conduire et qui sera une réflexion qui
sera plutôt dans une philosophie de
liberté des collectivités locales que
dans celle du la centralisation étatiste
dire est développé par grand paris
aménagement une fusion des structures
qui serait un premier pas vers une
probable fusion des départements
contestée par l'opposition
nous sommes pour des coopérations entre
collectivités
de là à aller jusqu'à la fusion il ya un
pas que nous franchissons pas parce que
aucun élu qui a siégé ce matin n'avaient
cette proposition dans son programme
à l'ordre du jour le vote du budget
primitif 2016 et la création d'un budget
annexe un budget light selon les
présidents d'un montant de 440 6000
euros réduit pour l'essentiel à
l'archéologie préventive